[Music] off the draw Lo but scars right
from the face off toon chams it in it's
one nothing Well speaking about size
you got a puck battle in front of the
go tender Mike and cson who 64 220 just
basically won that battle yeah he just
the puck back squirted back and he just out
battled them Mike Vernon's right big body
oh he got surprise sends one to the goal and it
finds its way through the Pearly Gates and it's
two to nothing he was going for a line chain oh
my goodness it might have hit r m we'll have to
see another angle of that boy that fourth line
for the Red Wings with fost that energy GRE y
they got another another deflection it's three
[Music] nothing who goal's going to stand oh
yeah CLK in the fabric in for shro check pack they
scar Raymond oh my God the floodgates have opened
the sellout crowd on their feet PR goals in 29
seconds as the Sharks come ahead short-handed
hurdle with eckan hurdle shoots and scores the
shark first short-handed goal of the Season
it stops the leading and it's 4-1 and Ruda will
clear it ahead and now a foot race and a breakway
zland in alone scores two short-handed goals
on the same penalty kill and it's 42 I don't
know what's going on and Burrows will send
it ahead for vasic he's got it with sterm he
scores three in a row and it's
43 unbelievable here in Detroit as Nico
Sturm brings the Sharks back to within
one I don't know what to say granin or make it
leank wh sterm two on one Bailey s go they've come
back from 4 nothing down in the same period it's
tied and Sturm has two in a row this is absolutely
incredible I I I can't remember Randy a period
like this ever in all our years together with the
sharks this is a period of legendary performance
by the sharks that first they would fall down for
nothing the way they did after dominating the
first period of this game and now they've come
back and tied it all within the same half a period
and we've had eight goals here in the second and
we are right back where we started coming into
this period we've played 40 wild minutes here
in Detroit after two periods it's the Sharks four
can't believe I'm saying it and the Red Wings four